so I moved to New York when I was 20 I
just did a couple of super Indies in a
row and I was kind of like yeah I want
to be like a serious actor doing dark
little Indies and stuff but then I
realized that I had to pay my rent Sex
in the City I guess that was my first
role in a TV show that was on the air I
played a character who can only have sex
in public places like he liked the idea
of getting caught it was fun because I
character was kind of absurd and it sort
of structured coordinate I remember
being in a Bed Bath and Beyond and
somebody saying oh man I say we just
have sex in the city and I was like yeah
I was what's it to the surprise I knew
the casting director on that Georgeann
Walken and she said they're looking for
a new character will you come out and
meet David chase out at Silvercup in
Queens and I was looking all right so I
get out there and then when I got there
she goes listen he's written one line
for this next episode where you just go
I would just have one line I was like
okay and she goes you know would you
read this one line so I walk in and he's
there how you doing I sit down in
employment and she goes up you ready to
go and go yeah and she goes okay
and actually when I go line killed in
that room and he liked it a lot David
Chase liked it the same and I think
that's how I took the part just cuz I
was ballsy enough to do that I guess a
big word Arrested Development it's kind
of a long story but it liked it it came
about because I lost another job the
year before and I was really bummed
about it add to this show called mike
omalley show with a bunch of friends in
1999 my character got written now it's a
series that was kind of taking it hard
and I was decided that I wasn't gonna do
any more TV I was really gonna stick it
to the TV biz like they'd notice and and
then this part came about and I went in
I sort of begrudgingly I kept saying I
don't wanna I'm not gonna do it I'm not
gonna read for anything and they said
just this woman call me and she said
it's a great part for you so I went
uptown and took the subway and reading
my my sides and put it on tape and then
forgot about it and then the next day
they're like um you know they want to
fly you to California to come read for
this for the network I was like all
right let me check my skedge I didn't
have the schedule that was the thing and
then yeah it just kind of changed
everything the second season I feel like
we really kind of found our groove and
got good at doing certain things and
understanding what really makes the show
work even though the third season you
know I think we started to get the
writing was on the wall that it was
gonna get cancelled and so then we were
sort of driven by defiance as the kind
of the underdogs and that kind of drove
story a lot and there were the result
was it kind of a Gallo sensibility to it
as well just because there was this
looming you know axe that was gonna end
the show I get people running up and
asking me to do they'll just yell come
on in my face or they'll ask me to do it
chicken dance or they'll ask whatever
and you know it's it's great I'm always
happy when people are an actual fan of
the show and they're like I love the
show and here's why and I love this I
love it and they're really into it then
yeah you got all the time in the world
for it because you're doing something
that you want you want people to enjoy
and to get something out of my real life
magic skills are super bad dirty rock I
was really happy when I got an email
from from Tina and saying you know we've
got this character or that I think that
you'll dig I didn't really know I liked
that well we'd been a few times but you
know just
such a fan I think that he's superior
performer he just oozes it he's just so
incredible so I was psyched we had a lot
of fun because our characters were you
know they were such sort of like arch
versions of ourselves or whatever we
would have a lot of we have a lot of
face offs like actual face offs or faces
that our noses get really close to each
other and we both kind of lower our
voices as much as we could and then
worst part is I wouldn't even want the
money
no you wouldn't jack down and keep
taking welfare to kill you for so many
jobs at stake you'd have to take it I'd
make you I'd make you take it off I'd
roll over and let you give it to me I'm
honestly not trying to make this sound
ya know one is just happening Plus you
know my character was kind of insane and
have a lot of like in the same entrances
and exits there would always make us
laugh I could just come my character
would often come like kind of wheeling
into the room like let me tell you
something jack
you know coming off of Arrested
Development it was a little bit of a
different vibe but also just in pursuit
of the same thing which was just to make
people laugh
you always find that that when you work
on shows like arrested or three rock
that the one kind of common theme with
the people involved is that they're
really just trying to make each other
laugh in the process like that's where
the magic is and if that happens then it
usually translates
that was a really fun experience you
know I of course I knew Andy they were
on SNL at the time and he was on it and
Akiva and your were writing on it and
making their digital shorts Andy had
been on arrested in a small part and
arrested and a hot rod they started
writing that and then they said hey why
don't you come and do it and I remember
flying to Vancouver and like on the
plane an hour into the flight thinking
like oh man I'm getting super sick right
now like it's just one of those and I
was in Vancouver for like three days
shooting all my stuff right and I was
crazy sick the entire time I was
shooting that so I was unlike any
histamines and stuff I was kind of out
of it and doing that insane character
and you know people are trying to stay
away from me it was you know so was such
a kind of a hazy it's such a weird
experience for me that when people often
say to me like hey man I love hot rod
and I love that thing and I'm kind of
I'm kind of like oh yeah my memory of it
is so foggy but it was really it was
really fun and dynamic bride is somebody
you know who was in it as well and
haters in it and it was like just a fun
cut and then Isla who I think is super
super funny you know she's one of those
people she's just a naturally funny
person very fun memories
[Music]
babe wait babe babe babe babe wait babe
no babe no babe no
[Music]
I was just trying to make like your man
aqui Villa and Andi laughs I think again
I think I was kind of out of it and they
just didn't yell cut so I just kept
going babe and just like well if you
guys don't yell a cut I'm just gonna
keep going and and I don't care you know
and that's how that kind of came about
again I was you know always just trying
to make them laugh like you you just
want them to break you know so I will do
whatever it takes to kind of [ __ ] with
them and then that's what they end up
you see Laurie that movie was a really
fun experience because we shot the first
few weeks up in in Canada and Montreal
crazy cold day one we did this scene I
remember where we are running into the
mall we're both slipping because we're
on our skates and it was just so
physical it was truly just two
ten-year-olds playing yeah we're on
skates and then we had to get them
blocked and the in the grooves of the
escalator that to me is like a such a
funny comedic beat which is the wild
chase then they get stuck for a second
they can't change the space cause
they're both locked in and they're
forced to have a kind of a conversation
where and we'll kind of turns to me and
says like who are you supposed to be and
I'm like this JFK who are you supposed
to be anyway Rod Serling JFK
it's gonna make sense we got to do a lot
of skating which you know as a Canadian
I can skate a little bit so of the four
people who were really featured skaters
in the movie I got to do probably the
most actual skating which was fun
brother then brother Salman was one of
the funniest if not funniest script I've
ever read 14 I are good friends but back
then he was on SNL and he had had all
these drawings and he had all this weird
stuff about these two brothers these
characters he wanted to do he gave me
the script and he said that you know
I've been thinking about these two
characters who were brothers and I've
got this script that I wrote basically
for us to do for you and me to do you
know and somebody says that you're
killing well let's see and it was just
unbelievably funny and brilliant and so
specific and so specific - will - he's
one of those guys like I he really makes
me laugh I just love his perspective I
think it's so interesting and funny I
don't know if we executed it perfectly
I've always felt like it deserved a
little bit better a nice to joke we
should go back and remake it and the
budget should be what it made on its
opening weekend and it only made like
the opening weekend it was something
crazy
it was like 550 grand or something was
it like the definition of a bomb Bojack
horseman
so Raphael bob-waksberg who created this
show he and I have the same manager and
Raphael wrote this script it's about a
guy who's a horse living in a world
that's populated by animals and humans
it sounds like it sounds great and then
so I read it it was just instantly
really funny and different we didn't
have a deal with anybody to make so we
made like a short presentation and then
we went out with it and everybody pass
on it and then it almost happened we
almost sold it to a network and then the
last minute they backed out and so there
was it looked like it was just dead then
Ted Saran doze watched it and he was
like yeah I like this I think it's funny
you guys can make it here
really great because you I don't think
that any kind of market research would
bear out that there'd be an audience for
it takes lots of dips and turns and
really surprising a lot of levels it's
been one of those things they've been
really proud to be a part of weirdly
it's a story told about and by you know
animals and whatever insects and and yet
funnily enough all the the stories are
actually very human stories the lego
movie a new Phil and and Chris we had
worked together on a they made a film
called Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs
and originally I was in I was gonna do
that and they had a much darker vision
for that film originally and the studio
got scared and rightfully so it's not
gonna attract a big kids audience and
what are we doing here they threw the
whole thing out and then included me and
an Amy Poehler we were both doing it
together so I think Phil and Chris felt
kind of bad about it and so a couple of
years later they called me one day and
they're like listen we're making the
lego movie at Warner Brothers and we
want you to play Batman and we're gonna
put a thing in your contract where
nothing can happen to you and we feel so
bad about what went up like it was all
like in one sense I was like guys first
lego movie I don't know what that means
but sure and also we're fine started
recording and trying to find the voice
of Batman in what was making us laugh
about him well yeah what's really making
fun of Christian Bale it was more like
looking at as the Batman had progressed
it's gotten that voice has gotten more
and more deep and raspbian kind of feels
almost like a caricature or like it's
it's almost sounds like somebody else is
saying it you know you see him as Bruce
Wayne and then he puts the cowl on and
gets in the car and he is like where we
going let's go there do like wait what
happened and we just loved the idea of
seeing that guy having that voice all
the time in every aspect to his life
when he's making food when he's trying
to quarter a movie when he's you know
doing whatever Teen Titans go to the
movies for the most part you don't work
together Teen Titans go I did I said
most of it on my own
returns yeah well you know I'm really
regretting asking Jimin to do it now
because he's been shoving it in my face
a little bit and he he was hell-bent on
making sure my kids knew we were on
spring break and he was like he says to
my kids think so your dad told you right
that there's a new new Batman
we good we rapped in here
[Music]